Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app over a now peaceful world. Great upheavals, terrible struggles, wars such as one cannot imagine.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告干扰音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告节目并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，也可以直接在应用内订阅……这个曾经宁静的世界。巨大的动荡、可怕的斗争、人们无法想象的战争。
And I tell you, London will be in danger. London will be attacked. And I shall be very prominent in the defence of London. I see further ahead than you do. I see into the future. This country will be subjected somehow to a tremendous invasion, by what means I do not know. But I tell you, I shall be in command of the defence of London and I shall save London and England. Dominic, no question who that was, because the impression was absolutely spot on. That was, of course, Winston Churchill. But Dominic, I'm playing a trick because he didn't actually sound like that because when he said that he was 16. He was a harrow and he was he was looking into the future um and it's a reminder
我告诉你们，伦敦将面临危险。伦敦将被攻击。而且我将在保卫伦敦的战斗中发挥极其重要的作用。我比你们看得更远。我能预见未来。这个国家将以某种方式遭受极其惨烈的入侵，具体形式我不得而知。但我告诉你们，我将指挥伦敦的防卫，我将拯救伦敦和英格兰。多米尼克，毫无疑问那是谁，因为那种模仿简直绝了。那当然是温斯顿·丘吉尔。但是多米尼克，我在开玩笑，因为他听起来其实并不像那样，因为他说那番话时才16岁。他当时在哈罗公学，而且他当时在展望未来……嗯，这提醒了我们……
so if we you know with wordsworth we say the child is father to the man the idea of churchill as the savior of his nation was there in the great man's head perhaps right from the very beginning um and so you suggested didn't you that it might be fun to do not not because we haven't actually done any episodes focused on churchill up until now but to do one looking at young churchill the making of the man yes tom so that was 1891 the summer of 1891 and churchill was a harrow uh he had gone to chapel it's a funny story he'd gone to chapel even song and he and his friend merlin evans who went on to become a funny story. He'd gone to chapel, even song. And he and his friend Merlin Evans, who went on to become a diplomat, they went back to their boarding house.
所以如果我们用华兹华斯的话说“孩子是父亲的父亲”，那么丘吉尔作为国家拯救者的理念，或许从一开始就已经在这个伟大人物的脑海中萌芽了。嗯，所以你提议说，做一个这样的主题可能会很有趣——并不是说我们到现在为止还没有做过任何以丘吉尔为主题的节目，而是做一个聚焦于年轻丘吉尔、探究其人格塑造过程的节目。是的，汤姆，那是在1891年，1891年的夏天，丘吉尔当时在哈罗公学。他去参加了礼拜，这是一个有趣的故事，他去参加了晚祷。他和他的朋友梅林·埃文斯——他后来成为……这是一个有趣的故事，他去参加了晚祷。他和他的朋友梅林·埃文斯（后来成为了一名外交官）一起回到了他们的寄宿宿舍。
And they were just sort of messing around as teenagers are just chatting. And they talk about what they're going to do when they grow up. And I think Merlin Evans says, well, I'll probably be a diplomat like my father. And Churchill, as your uncanny impersonation captures, basically i'm gonna save the empire and um of course if it was anybody else well if it was if it was anybody you would say what a demented and incredibly bumptious thing and ludicrous thing for teenage boys but it was very well i mean there's a lot of bumptiousness in churchill's story isn't there but but it's not just the bumptiousness it's also the the slight faith in the supernatural the sense of a kind of destiny um a sense of the weird as the uh the anglo-saxons might put it because he he was interested in the idea that the future could
然后他们就像青少年一样只是在胡闹、闲聊。他们谈论长大后要做什么。我想梅林·埃文斯说，嗯，我大概会像我父亲一样成为一名外交官。而丘吉尔，正如你那神乎其技的模仿所展现的，基本上就是“我要拯救帝国”。而且嗯，当然，如果换作是别人，如果是任何其他人的话，你会觉得这是一件多么精神错乱、极其自大且荒谬可笑的事情，尤其是对十几岁的男孩来说。但那……我的意思是在丘吉尔的故事里有很多这种自大，不是吗？但不仅是自大，还有对超自然现象的一丝信仰，一种命运降临的感觉，一种……就像盎格鲁-撒克逊人可能会说的那样，“诡异”的感觉，因为他对未来可以……
be foretold because um a few years later in 1898 he gets taken by his aunt to see a woman called Mrs. Charlotte Robinson, who apparently was the most famous palm reader of the day. So he took over. What did Mrs. Robinson discover? He will save the empire. So Churchill, right from the beginning, has a sense of his own destiny, that he's destined for great things. And when he goes off on campaign,
被预知这个想法很感兴趣，因为……几年后的1898年，他的姑妈带他去见了一位名叫夏洛特·鲁滨逊夫人的女士，据说她是当时最著名的手相学家。于是他接过了话头。鲁滨逊夫人发现了什么？他将拯救帝国。所以丘吉尔从一开始就有一种命运感，觉得自己注定要成就伟大事业。而当他出征时，
when bullets are pinging around him, when he's performing, frankly, insane feats of courage and bravery, he seems to do it almost in the consciousness that he is fated to survive, that he could not have been born simply to be snuffed out, you know, in some obscure skirmish on the Northwest frontier, that he has been born and is living for some great purpose. And he does seem to have taken that relatively serious, doesn't he? He definitely thinks that his life is a great drama. So Andrew Roberts' biography, the most recent biography, is sort of the theme of it, is this idea. It sort of takes its cue from these famous words that Churchill writes after he became Prime Minister. So in the summer of 1940,
当子弹在他身边呼啸，当他表现出坦率地说近乎疯狂的勇气和无畏时，他似乎几乎是带着一种“自己注定能幸存”的信念在这样做，他绝不可能只是为了在西北边境的某场无名小冲突中默默无闻地死去而出生，他生来就是为了某个伟大的目的而活着的。而且他似乎把这一点看得相当严肃，不是吗？他绝对认为自己的人生是一部宏大的戏剧。所以安德鲁·罗伯茨（Andrew Roberts）的传记——最新的一部传记——其核心主题正是这种观点。它借鉴了丘吉尔在成为首相后写下的那些名言。所以在1940年的夏天，
when Britain is at its lowest ebb in the Second World War, facing apparent Nazi invasion and so on. And Churchill famously wrote afterwards, I felt as if I were walking with destiny, and that all my past life had been but a preparation for this hour and this trial. And it's sort of the classic sort of slightly overblown, grandiose thing that Churchill says and writes. And yet you're absolutely right, I think, that he believed it. He believed he was walking with destiny. The other funny thing, though, is that his father died young and Churchill will come on to his father because it's an absolutely engrossing, fascinating story about Churchill's relationship with his family and how that formed him. But his father died young, and I think Churchill, you know,
当时英国在第二次世界大战中正处于最低谷，面临着显而易见的纳粹入侵等等危机。丘吉尔后来有一句名言：“我觉得自己仿佛在与命运同行，我过去的一生不过是为这一时刻和这一考验做准备。”这有点像丘吉尔那种经典、略显夸张和宏大的言论和文字。然而，你的看法绝对没错，我认为他是深信不疑的。他相信自己正与命运同行。不过，另一个有趣的事实是，他的父亲很年轻就去世了——丘吉尔接下来就会谈到他的父亲，因为这是一个极其引人入胜、迷人的故事，关于丘吉尔与家庭的关系以及这种关系是如何塑造他的。但他的父亲英年早逝，我想丘吉尔……
he thought he would probably have 40 to 50 years on earth, and he was determined to wring out of them in a way that puts the rest of us, makes the rest of us feel so limp and pallid by comparison. He was determined to wring out of every moment to an almost sort of superhuman degree and frankly i would agree that a lot of people found incredibly irritating he was determined to always be the center of attention always get the absolute the most fun and adventure out of every single moment yeah and and it's almost kind of scandalous isn't it it's it's a cause of scandal his determination to be the center of attention everywhere. But it's clearly really, really important. So 1897, a year before he goes to see the palm reader, he's on the Hindu Kusha and he writes to his mother, I have faith in my star conviction that you have to be born into the aristocracy of the greatest power on the face of the earth, really, to feel blazing within you from the early years, do you think?
他原本以为自己在世上大概还会有40到50年的时间，他决心将这些时间榨取到极致，相比之下，让我们这些其他人感到自己是如此的软弱和苍白无力。他决心从每一个时刻中榨取出近乎超人的价值，坦率地说，我也同意这一点——许多人觉得这极其恼人。他决心永远成为所有人瞩目的焦点，永远从每一个瞬间中榨取绝对最多的乐趣和冒险。是的，这几乎可以说是某种丑闻，不是吗？他这种决心要在任何地方都成为焦点的情况，引发了种种非议。但这显然真的、真的很重要。所以在1897年，在他去见手相学家的一年前，他在兴都库什山脉，他写信给母亲：“我相信我的星象，坚信你必须出生在地球上最伟大力量的贵族阶层中，才能从早年起就在内心熊熊燃烧……”你觉得呢？
I suppose so, Tom. I mean, it's the kind of thing a Roman senator might have said or someone at the top of the chinese imperial apparatus it's easier to think that if of course if you have the habit of global rule and you're at the top of you're the top of the social pyramid i mean churchill is incredibly pampered all his life he doesn't ever have to cook for himself there's this famous thing i saw you put the quotation on twitter i i his wife asks him if he could cook or something. In the 1950s, he says, I can boil an egg. I have seen it done.
我想是的，汤姆。我的意思是，这就像是一个罗马参议员可能会说的话，或者中国帝制机器顶层的人可能会说的话。如果你习惯了全球统治，并且身处社会金字塔的顶端，这种想法自然更容易产生。我的意思是，丘吉尔一生都被极度溺爱，他从来不需要自己做饭。有一件很有名的事情——我看到你把这句引言发在了推特上——他的妻子问他会不会做饭什么的。在20世纪50年代，他说：“我会煮鸡蛋。我亲眼看别人做过。”
But then he never actually does it. He could pour out champagne. Yes. He once writes, I think when he's a teenager, he writes to his parents or to one of his friends or something, and he says that he's had the ultimate indignity. He's had to travel second class on the train. He'll never do it again.
但他实际上从未自己动过手。他会倒香槟。是的。他曾经写道——我想是在他还是个青少年的时候——他写信给父母或某个朋友什么的，说他遭遇了终极羞辱。他不得不坐火车的二等座。他发誓再也不这样了。
I will never travel second again by Jove. So this, you're absolutely right, he's completely spoiled and well, he is and he isn't. We should come on to, because when you tell the life story of Churchill, the young Churchill, one of the nice things
“我向朱庇特发誓，我再也不会坐二等座了。”所以这一点你完全没错，他被彻底宠坏了……不过话又说回来，他既被宠坏了，又没有完全被宠坏。我们接下来该谈谈这个，因为当你讲述丘吉尔的人生故事、也就是年轻的丘吉尔时，其中一个美妙之处在于，
about it is we don't have to get into all the controversies that attend his later years yet, because they're far around the corner. But also, that life story is actually, in many ways, it seems like it's going to be the narrative of somebody who ends up terribly disturbed or an utter failure, because he has actually a pretty awful family upbringing. His parents treat him abysmally and i always think the story of churchill i i don't think i've apart from maybe general gordon i don't think i've had as much fun researching a subject for the rest of history as i did with this it is isn't it he is such an ebullient character he's also conscious of himself as a character so his book my early life is an
我们还不必卷入那些围绕着他晚年生活的种种争议，因为那些离现在还很远。但同时，那个生活故事实际上在许多方面看起来，倒像是一个最终会变得精神极度错乱或彻底失败之人的剧本，因为他其实有着相当糟糕的家庭成长经历。他的父母对他的态度极其恶劣。而且我一直觉得丘吉尔的故事……除了戈登将军之外，我想我没有在研究《历史的余烬》的任何主题时，像研究这个时这样感到如此快乐。确实如此，对吧？他是一个如此热情洋溢的角色，他同时也意识到自己是一个“文学形象”，所以他的书《我早年的生活》（My Early Life）是一部
absolutely wonderful read and if listeners you, if they take anything from this podcast, you know, you can read it online. It's funny. It's one of the great autobiographies, actually. I think one of the most enjoyable autobiographies. Well, it's – so when he was at Harrow, he was addicted to tales of Daring Do, Ryder Haggard and all that kind of stuff. And in a way, he goes out and he leads that kind of life. And Conan Doyle, who was a war correspondent with him in South Africa, not as well paid as Churchill, because Churchill by that point was the best paid war correspondent probably in the world. But he said that of Churchill's prose know it was the most masterly and that that ability of churchill not just to write an adventure story but to situate
绝对精彩绝伦的读物。如果听众们能从这个播客中有所收获的话，你知道的，你可以在网上读到它。它非常有趣。事实上，它是最伟大的自传之一。我认为是最引人入胜的自传之一。嗯，它是这样的——当他在哈罗公学时，他痴迷于那些惊险刺激的故事，比如莱德·哈格德（Ryder Haggard）之类的小说。某种程度上，他走出校门，也过上了那种生活。柯南·道尔（Conan Doyle）曾在南非担任与他同行的战地记者，收入没有丘吉尔高，因为丘吉尔当时可能是世界上收入最高的战地记者。但他说，从丘吉尔的散文中可以看出，那是极其精湛的，而丘吉尔不仅能写出冒险故事，还能将
himself in the center of it is pretty unique i think yeah i mean really i'm trying to i mean maybe caesar nobody else really yes for people who hate Churchill, it must be very annoying that he's such a good writer, as well as his life contains so many episodes of conspicuous courage. You know, it's impossible to dislike him after reading all these stories. You said the controversy is part. I mean, one of the things, of course, that has made Churchill controversial is that he's an unabashed apologist for the empire. I mean, he loves the empire. He loves everything about it. And what he loves about the empire is the
自己置身于故事中心的能力，我认为是相当独特的。是的，我的意思是，真的，我试图去想——或许除了凯萨，真的没有别人了。是的，对于那些痛恨丘吉尔的人来说，他既是一个如此出色的作家，而他的一生又包含如此多显著勇敢的事迹，这一定非常令人恼火。你知道，在读完所有这些故事后，根本不可能讨厌他。你刚才说争议是其中一部分。我的意思是，当然，让丘吉尔备受争议的原因之一，是他对帝国毫不掩饰的辩护。我的意思是，他热爱帝国。他热爱关于它的一切。而他对帝国的热爱，正是
kind of thing that enthused people in the 1890s and the 1900s. So in other words, it's not about tariffs or imperial preference or all the kind of, you know, the economic side of it. It's the dash, it's the colour. It's the kind of thing that James Morris, who then became Jan Morris, wrote about in her great trilogy about the British Empire. It's the colour, it's the swagger of it, it's the fun of it. And when I say the fun of it, it's the fun of it if you are a British adventurer, surviving endless scrapes, and then coming back and being able to write it up. And that, I think, is what Churchill is all about. He sees it as a playground, I think, as a colossal playground where he can go and have adventures at the drop of a hat.
那种在19世纪90年代和20世纪00年代让人狂热的东西。换句话说，这无关关税、帝国特惠制或所有那些经济层面的东西。这是那种冲劲，那种色彩。就像詹姆斯·莫里斯（后来成为简·莫里斯 Jan Morris）在她关于大英帝国的伟大三部曲中所写的那样。那是色彩，是帝国的气势，是其中的乐趣。而当我说是其中的乐趣时，如果你是一个英国冒险家，在无尽的艰难险阻中幸存下来，然后回来将其写成文字，这就是其中的乐趣。我想，这就是丘吉尔的全部意义所在。他把帝国视为一个游乐场，我认为是一个巨大的游乐场，他可以在那里说走就走，去经历冒险。
It's a kind of computer game, a real computer game, that kind of thing where you go from level to level and you have adventure after adventure. It's that kind of thing, I think. So there are all these episodes to come, which we will turn to. So he goes to Cuba. He goes to the Northwest Frontier. He goes to the Sudan. I mean, that's an incredible story.
这就像是一种电脑游戏，一个真实的电脑游戏，那种从一个关卡打到下一个关卡、不断经历冒险的游戏。我想就是那种东西。所以接下来还有很多这样的插曲，我们后面都会讲到。所以他去了古巴。他去了西北边境。他去了苏丹。我的意思是，那是一个难以置信的故事。
And then, of course, South Africa, when he's taken prisoner and he escapes from the Boer. Well, actually, it's like Flashman, isn't it? It's like the way that Flashman pops up in every major campaign going. For a brief period, Churchill is at the heart of every imperial adventure that there is i mean it's astonishing and i i'm going to confess dominic that i i have never read a straight biography of churchill i just kind of and it's a terrible thing to admit but i um it's a bit like people who say they've never listened to a beatles album all the way through because it's ubiquitous it's ubiquitous so i kind of have a vague sense of the story but like you i found i
然后，当然还有南非，他在那里被俘并从布尔人手中逃脱。嗯，实际上，这就很像弗拉什曼（Flashman），不是吗？就像弗拉什曼总能在每一场重大战役中突然冒出来一样。在一段短暂的时间里，丘吉尔成为了当时每一次帝国冒险的核心。我的意思是这太惊人了。多米尼克，我要承认，我从来没有读过一本正经经八百的丘吉尔传记。我只是……承认这一点太糟糕了，但我……这有点像那些说自己从来没有完整听过一张披头士专辑的人一样，因为这太无处不在了。它无处不在，所以我对这个故事有一种模糊的概念，但像你一样，我发现
found this just riotously entertaining and i had no idea well at least i had no i hadn't fully understood just how dramatic a story this is yeah it really is brilliant and i think the comparison with general gordon is is exact except that general gordon was a much more austere serious self-contained figure whereas churchill you would it was none of those things well churchill has two things i think which will really come out in this story one is he really does even if you despise churchill you despise the empire he despises everything he stood for he has an absolutely tremendous sense of humor and he's very aware of himself as a comic character, as well as a heroic one.
这实在是让人捧腹大笑、极其有趣，而且我根本不知道——或者说至少我之前并没有完全意识到，这是一个多么具有戏剧性的故事。是的，这真的很精彩，而且我认为将他与戈登将军作对比非常贴切，只不过戈登将军是一个更加严厉、严肃、内敛的人物，而丘吉尔则完全不是这样。嗯，丘吉尔有两点特质，我想在这段故事中会非常显露出来：第一，即便你鄙视丘吉尔，鄙视帝国，鄙视他所代表的一切，他也确实有着极强的幽默感，并且他非常清楚自己既是一个喜剧人物，也是一个英雄人物。
So I think that's one thing. But he also has this enormous generosity of spirit, actually. So the way he talks about his adversaries, we'll come onto this, in the Northwest Frontier, or on the Northwest Frontier, in the Sudan, there is a sort of, and it was a terrible cliche, there is an irrepressible humanity to him. He never demonizes the people he's sort of
所以我想这是一点。但实际上，他也有一种极其博大的精神气度。他在谈论自己的对手时——我们后面会讲到这一点——在西北边境，或者在西北边境、在苏丹，有一种……虽然这是一个可怕的老生常谈，但他身上有一种不可遏制的仁慈人性。他从来不把那些他正朝其
shooting at in fact he often says what tremendously noble opponents they are all this kind of thing um which makes him a very endearing character i think to to read about so should we start at the beginning tom yes and i suppose at the beginning really is um john churchill who becomes the first duke of marlborough would you say yeah i suppose so because he's the great model for churchill he's his ancestor it's very important to churchill um that he's descended from marlborough in the tv film the gathering storm where albert finney played churchill so it's about churchill in the 1930s about 20 years ago lovely film actually that starts with churchill having a vision of marlborough at the battle of blenheim so having won the battle of blenheim in 1704, Churchill's great ancestor, the Duke of Marlborough,
开枪的人妖魔化，事实上，他经常说他们是多么值得尊敬的对手之类的话。这使得他在被阅读时，成了一个非常惹人喜爱的角色。那么，汤姆，我们应该从头开始讲起吗？好的，我想这个“开头”实际上就是……约翰·丘吉尔（John Churchill），也就是第一代马尔巴罗公爵（Duke of Marlborough），你觉得呢？是的，我想是的，因为他是丘吉尔伟大的榜样，是他的祖先。这对丘吉尔来说非常重要，
was rewarded with Blenheim Palace, the most magnificent house in England, if not perhaps in Europe. Do you know what he wrote on the evening of the Battle of Blenheim in his diary? No. He wrote, won the Battle of Blenheim, which is one of my favourite ever diary entries. So he was already conscious of it being the Battle of Blenheim, which is one of my favourite ever diary entries. So he was already conscious of it being the Battle of Blenheim. Yeah, he was. Well, because he named it, because he'd won it. So he had the right to name it. So we should just say, shouldn't we, that this is part of a European land war in which the British land forces win a succession of astonishing victories, almost entirely due to the generalship
他自己是马尔巴罗的后代。在大约20年前的一部电视电影《风雨同舟》（The Gathering Storm）中，阿尔伯特·芬尼（Albert Finney）饰演了丘吉尔——讲的是20世纪30年代的丘吉尔，那是一部很棒的电影——影片的开场就是丘吉尔在布伦海姆战役中幻视到马尔巴罗。1704年赢得布伦海姆战役后，丘吉尔伟大的祖先马尔巴罗公爵，
of John Churchill, who becomes the Duke of Marlborough. And he gets given this enormous house, kind of Versailles of England, Blenheim Palace. And this in due course is where Churchill will be born. Right, exactly. So it's 1874. It's the 30th of November, 1874, 1.30 in the morning. It's in a ground floor room.
获得了布伦海姆宫（Blenheim Palace）作为奖赏，这是英格兰、甚至可能是全欧洲最宏伟的宅邸。你知道他在布伦海姆战役当晚的日记里写了什么吗？不知道。他写道：“赢得了布伦海姆战役。”这是我最喜欢的日记内容之一。所以他当时就已经意识到这是一场布伦海姆战役了，这是我最喜欢的日记内容之一。所以他当时就已经意识到……是的，他确实意识到了。嗯，因为是他命名的，因为是他打赢的。所以他有权为它命名。那么我们应该说，对吧，这是欧洲一场土地战争的一部分，在这场战争中，英国陆军接连赢得了惊人的胜利，这几乎完全归功于约翰·丘吉尔（后来的马尔巴罗公爵）的卓越指挥艺术。
His mother is an american socialite called jenny jerome and his father is lord randolph churchill who is a younger son of the duke of marlborough and you know where they met i do and i thought you would love this detail so they met no you tell you tell me you tell us because i know it means a lot to you so they met at uh the yachting regatta at cows and one can only assume that both of them were wearing the correct footwear because it was um it was a whirlwind romance wasn't it was a genuine passion of the heart lord randolph who is an a young tory politician kind of up-and-coming tory populist politician but second son so that's a key detail
他被赠予了这座巨大的宅邸——英国的凡尔赛宫，也就是布伦海姆宫。而丘吉尔也将在不久后在这里出生。没错，完全正确。那是1874年。1874年11月30日，凌晨1点30分。地点在一间一楼的房间里。
exactly he proposed after three days to jenny jerome um so it's a key detail. Exactly. He proposed after three days to Jenny Jerome. So it's a genuine love match. And actually in later life, when people were rude about Churchill's parents, even after they were dead, Churchill sued them. Churchill sued them for libel. Somebody described him in 1937 as the first fruit of the first famous snob dollar marriage and churchill was outraged and won 500 pounds in damages from the publishers because he said it had been a genuine love match and it was very important to him yeah he thought his parent will come on to the extraordinary sentimental romanticization that churchill does of his parents who were both absolutely terrible people. Yes, they really were. But I mean, the force of that criticism that so upset Churchill was that it becomes a cliche, doesn't it? It becomes a kind of stereotype
他的母亲是一位名叫珍妮·杰罗姆（Jenny Jerome）的美国社交名媛，他的父亲是伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵（Lord Randolph Churchill），他是马尔巴罗公爵的小儿子。你知道他们是在哪里相遇的吗？我知道，而且我觉得你会喜欢这个细节。不，你来告诉大家，你来告诉我们，因为我知道这对你意义重大。他们相遇于……在考斯（Cowes）的游艇帆船赛上，人们只能假设他们俩当时都穿着得体的鞋袜，因为那是一场……那是一场旋风般的恋爱，不是吗？那是发自内心的真挚热恋。伦道夫勋爵是一位年轻的托利党政客，是个冉冉升起的托利党民粹主义政客，但他是个次子，所以这是一个关键细节。
of the impoverished English aristocrat marrying up with the daughter of some American plutocrat. And Jenny Churchill's father, I mean, he'd lost quite a lot of money in a kind of some crash or something that had happened that were always happening in America. Yeah, the crash of 1873. But I mean, he's still in the New York Times and a kind of vast chunk of Manhattan. And so he was quite well off. He was. And so that sense of being American as well as British obviously will be hugely important to Churchill, and particularly in the Second World War. But I mean, throughout his life.
没错。他在认识三天后就向珍妮·杰罗姆求婚了，所以这是一个关键细节。没错。他在三天后就向珍妮·杰罗姆求婚了。所以这是一场真挚的爱情。事实上，在晚年时，当人们对丘吉尔的父母说三道四时，甚至在他们死后，丘吉尔还将这些人告上法庭。丘吉尔以诽谤罪起诉了他们。1937年，有人形容他是“第一次著名的势利美元婚姻的头号恶果”，丘吉尔对此大为光火，并从出版商那里赢得了500英镑的损害赔偿金，因为他说这是一场真正的挚爱联姻，这对他非常重要。是的，他认为他的父母……我们等下会谈到丘吉尔对他的父母那种非同寻常的、浪漫化的美化，而他们俩其实绝对都是糟糕透顶的人。是的，他们确实如此。但我的意思是，让丘吉尔如此心烦意乱的批评力度在于，这成了一种老生常谈，不是吗？这成了一种刻板印象：
Definitely in later life, yeah. And I think, so those two characters, so Jenny Jerome, Jenny Churchill, she becomes, is a very, I don't want to be too harsh on her, but really she emerges from the story as a very spoiled, superficial, self-interested person. She has a series of affairs. She rocks a tight riding habit. She does. She wears her riding habits very tightly cut she's all she's like skittles the uh the
贫困的英国贵族娶了某个美国富豪的女儿。而珍妮·丘吉尔的父亲，我的意思是，他在美国接连发生的某种金融崩溃中损失了不少钱。是的，1873年恐慌。但我的意思是，他依然在《纽约时报》上频频出现，并且拥有曼哈顿的大片土地。所以他相当富有。他确实很富有。所以那种既是美国人又是英国人的身份意识，显然对丘吉尔至关重要，特别是在二战期间。但我的意思是，贯穿了他的一生。
mistress of the duke of cambridge are very much a friend of the rest is history she she's a society figure she's the kind of person who today would be constantly pictured in kind of gossip in hello magazine or or something and lord randolph so churchill's father he is i said he was a tory populist he's sort of disraelian politician and he's a conservative he believes in the empire and so on but he also he's sort of culture he's a demagogue and well his demagogue is too strong but he cultivates the masses mass appeal so he's he very much sort of believes in something he calls tory democracy which is sort of he gets asked doesn't he by a friend to to explain what he means by tory democracy to which lord randolph replied i believe it to
晚年绝对是这样的，是的。我认为，这两个角色——珍妮·杰罗姆，也就是珍妮·丘吉尔，她成为了……我不想对她太苛刻，但实际上她在故事中展现出来的是一个非常被宠坏的、肤浅的、自私自利的人。她有过好几段外遇。她穿着紧身骑马装。她确实如此。她把骑马装剪裁得非常紧身，她就像……就像剑桥公爵的情妇凯特尔（Skittles）一样——剑桥公爵的情妇也是《历史的余烬》的老朋友了。她是个社交名流，就是那种如果在今天，会不断出现在八卦杂志、如《Hello!》杂志或其他什么刊物上的人。至于伦道夫勋爵——也就是丘吉尔的父亲，我刚才说过他是个托利党民粹主义者，他是那种迪斯雷利式的政客，是个保守派，他相信帝国等等。但同时，他又有点文化，是个煽动家……嗯，说他是煽动家有点过头了，但他迎合大众，争取群众的支持。所以他非常坚信一种他称之为“托利党民主”（Tory democracy）的东西。当一个朋友要求他解释什么是“托利党民主”时，
be principally opportunism engaging the honest reply so it's basically about sort of whipping up he's great at whipping up crowds with talk of the kind of the queen, the empire, socialists are terribly bad people. The liberals are all kind of prigs and misery gutses. And he sort of panders to the crowds and is very sort of successful at doing that and very popular as a sort of rising force in the Conservative Party. But he's also incredibly unreliable. He's an absolute shower, isn't he? Yeah, he's a terrible man. Terry Thomas would play him.
伦道夫勋爵回答说：“我认为它主要就是机会主义。”这是一个相当诚实的回答。所以它基本上就是关于煽动……他非常擅长用女王、帝国、社会主义者是极其糟糕的人、自由党人全都是伪君子和扫兴鬼之类的话题来煽动民众。他迎合大众，在这方面非常成功，作为保守党内一股冉冉升起的新星也备受追捧。但他也极其不可靠，简直是个无可救药的废物，不是吗？是的，他是个糟糕透顶的男人。特里·托马斯（Terry Thomas）完全可以演他。
Yeah. But a sort of more sinister Terry Thomas, sort of syphilitic Terry Thomas. So I was reading Andrew Roberts' biography, and he talks about, so Churchill spends his early years in Dublin. You know, he's brought up in Dublin. And Lord Randolph has gone there to work as private secretary to his father, who has been appointed the Viceroy and Lord Lieutenant of Ireland by Disraeli.
是的。但有点像更阴险的特里·托马斯，那种带梅毒症状的特里·托马斯。所以我当时在读安德鲁·罗伯茨的传记，里面提到丘吉尔在都柏林度过了他的早年时光。你知道的，他在都柏林长大。而伦道夫勋爵去那里工作，担任他父亲的私人秘书——他的父亲被迪斯雷利任命为爱尔兰总督兼爱尔兰最高长官。
And Andrew Roberts has this sentence, which made my eyes pop. And I wanted to know more. Lord Randolph had to leave London because he was being socially ostracized by the Prince of Wales after trying unsuccessfully to blackmail him over a scandal involving Randolph's elder brother, the Marquess of Blanford, some compromising love letters and a married former mistress of the Prince. And Andrew Roberts just leaves that amazing sentence. Do you know what was going on there? I don't, but at the very next sentence, Andrew Roberts just says,
安德鲁·罗伯茨有这样一句话，让我大跌眼镜。我想了解更多：“伦道夫勋爵不得不离开伦敦，因为他在试图勒索威尔士亲王未果后，遭到了威尔士亲王发起的社交排挤。此前，伦道夫的长兄布兰福德侯爵（Marquess of Blandford）卷入了一桩丑闻，涉及一些暧昧的情书以及威尔士亲王的一位已婚前情妇。”安德鲁·罗伯茨就这样轻描淡写地留下了这句惊人的话。你知道当时是怎么回事吗？我不知道，但在接下来的紧接着的一句里，安德鲁·罗伯茨只是说：
it was one of the very many unedifying scrapes in which Lord Randolph found himself during his short, unstable, but undeniably exciting life. Yes, so Lord Randolph, I don't know the details of this scandal. I mean, obviously the future Edward VII, he was always being involved in scandals to do with cards and women and so on. And Lord Randolph clearly moves on the,
“这是伦道夫勋爵在他短暂、不稳定但绝对激动人心的生命中所陷入的众多不体面的风流韵事之一。”是的，所以伦道夫勋爵——我不知道这桩丑闻的细节。显然，未来的爱德华七世总是卷入扑克牌和女人之类的丑闻中。而伦道夫勋爵显然在这个圈子里混，
he moves in his set, but is just seen by everybody as this- Absolutely rotter. Talented, but utterly unt seen by everybody as this talented, but utterly untrustworthy and unreliable. I mean, actually, funny enough, Boris Johnson models himself on Winston Churchill, but Lord Randolph might be a better comparison. So Lord Randolph is sort of banned from London for three years,
但被所有人视为一个——绝对的无赖。一个有才华却完全不可信、不可靠的人。事实上，说来也滑稽，鲍里斯·约翰逊（Boris Johnson）以温斯顿·丘吉尔为榜样，但伦道夫勋爵可能是一个更贴切的对比。所以伦道夫勋爵被伦敦驱逐了三年，
and he goes off to Dublin. And that's where Winston has his first memories. So his very first memory he writes in my early life, he says, I remember my grandfather, the Viceroy, unveiling the statue of Lord Goff, who was an imperial hero in 1878. And he remembers his grandfather talking to the crowd and using a particular phrase,
他去了都柏林。而温斯顿就在那里留下了他最早的记忆。他在《我早年的生活》中写下了他最早的记忆：“我记得我的祖父——总督大人，在1878年为戈夫勋爵（Lord Gough，一位帝国英雄）的雕像揭幕。”他记得祖父对人群讲话时使用了一个特定的短语：
and with a withering volley, he shattered the enemy's line. Very kind of Churchillian phrase. Churchill claims that even though he was three, this phrase stuck in his memory. The other thing that's... So My Early Life is a genuinely very, very funny read. I mean, we have to stop the podcast just to generate into us reading out chunks. But the other thing that Churchill remembers from his time at Dublin,
“伴随着毁灭性的齐射，他粉碎了敌人的战线。”这是一个非常丘吉尔式的短语。丘吉尔声称，尽管他当时只有三岁，但这个短语深深印在了他的记忆里。另一件……《我早年的生活》是一部读起来极其、极其有趣的著作。我的意思是，我们不得不暂停播客，因为我们总是忍不住要朗读其中的大段内容。不过，丘吉尔对都柏林时期的另一个记忆是，
he says, they were booked to go to a pantomime. Did you see this, Tom? He's were booked to go to a pantomime. Did you see this, Tom? He's all excited about going to this pantomime. And he says, then we were told we could not go to the pantomime because the theatre had been burned down. All that was found for the manager was the key that had been in his pocket. We were promised as a consolation for not going to the pantomime to go the next day and see the ruins of the building.
他说，他们原本预定去看一场木偶哑剧（pantomime）。你看到了吗，汤姆？他们预定去看一场木偶哑剧。你看到这个了吗，汤姆？他对去看这场哑剧感到兴奋不已。然后他说，接着我们被告知不能去看哑剧了，因为剧院被烧毁了。管理员找到的唯一东西就是一直放在他口袋里的钥匙。作为没能去成哑剧的补偿，我们被承诺第二天去参观建筑物的废墟。
I wanted very much to see the key, but this request does not seem to have been well but it's brilliant isn't it because because it's you're seeing it through a child's eyes that's exactly the kind of thing a child would say and yes and it's it's a brilliant example of his ability to write prose i mean joyce would be proud of that you know the portrait of the artist's young man you know begins with the child's perspective and churchill's doing exactly the same there churchill is very good at getting into other people's heads in his books so there's a very very funny moment we'll come to where he talks about the obstacles that have been thrown in his path by people who think he's a he's a bumptious little sod basically and he's very funny at sort of imagining what they think of him but yes he so he's a he's a pretty
我很想看看那把钥匙，但这个请求似乎并没有得到很好的……但这个故事不是很精彩吗？因为你是透过一个孩子的眼睛在看，这正是一个孩子会说的话。是的，这是他驾驭散文能力的绝佳例证——乔伊斯如果知道了也会为之自豪的，你知道的，《青年艺术家的画像》开头就是从孩子的视角展开的，而丘吉尔在那里做的正是完全相同的事。丘吉尔在书中非常擅长进入别人的头脑。有一个非常、非常有趣的时刻——我们稍后会讲到——他谈到了阻挡在他面前的重重阻碍，这些阻碍来自那些认为他不过是个自大狂妄的小混蛋的人。他在想象这些人如何看待他时表现得极其幽默。但无论如何，他当时是个被宠坏的小男孩。他在都柏林，
spoiled little boy there he is in dublin he's got a colossal think of him but yes he so he's a he's a pretty spoiled little boy there he is in dublin he's got a colossal number of toy soldiers and he his friends later say he he's obsessed with guns with swords with the army with all these kind of things well the fact that he remembers that phrase from his grandfather about the um the withering volley shattering the enemy's line and then he has this he has this complete attic doesn't he's kind of playroom full of lines and lines of soldiers um suggests that this is really the wellspring of his his enthusiasm i mean this is what he really really loves but the counter to that is that he so it sounds like an idyllic childhood but as we said
有着数量惊人的玩具士兵。他后来的朋友们说，他对枪支、对剑、对军队以及所有这些东西都着迷。好吧，他能记住祖父关于“毁灭性的齐射粉碎敌人的战线”的那句话，然后他拥有一个完整的阁楼——他的游戏室里摆满了整排整排的士兵——这表明这确实是他热情的源泉。我的意思是，这才是他真正、真正热爱的东西。但与此相对的是，尽管这听起来像是一个田园诗般的童年，但正如我们所说，
his parents are just awful people and they really they could not treat him more neglectfully or okay let's let's take a break there because this is such an important theme and it's it's such a kind of sad story really that i think it it would benefit from um from a fresh. So we will see you back after this break and when we come back, a terrible tale of neglectful parenting. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
他的父母简直是糟糕透顶的人，他们对他的忽视和冷漠简直无以复加。好吧，我们就在这里休息一下吧，因为这是一个如此重要的主题，而且这是一个如此悲伤的故事，我想它值得我们……以崭新的状态继续探讨。稍事休息后，我们不见不散。接下来的节目中，将讲述一个关于忽视育儿的可怕故事。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. This episode of The Rest Is History is sponsored by UnHerd, the online magazine where you can read
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和八卦速递。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期《历史的余烬》由在线杂志 UnHerd 赞助。在这里，你可以阅读
some of British journalism's most brilliant and original thinkers, like me. And as our subject today is the young Winston Churchill, why not check out Will Lloyd's piece about The Churchill Factor, a biography of the great man by one Boris Johnson, whatever happened to him. Will says the point of the Churchill factor to kick enough biographical sand in people's eyes until when they looked up, they could no longer see where Churchill started and Johnson ended. Churchill's distractors, says Johnson, are snobbish and a teensy bit jealous, like Johnson's. Churchill's writing was a way of dramatizing and publicizing jealous, like Johnson's. Churchill's writing was a way of dramatising and publicising himself, like Johnson's. Churchill's disloyalty to party colleagues was magnificent, like Johnson's. It becomes absurd. In habits, Churchill, and I can't find
英国新闻界一些最才华横溢、最具原创性的思想家的文章，比如我。既然我们今天的主题是年轻的温斯顿·丘吉尔，为什么不去看看威尔·劳埃德（Will Lloyd）关于《丘吉尔因子》（The Churchill Factor）的文章呢？这本书是某位鲍里斯·约翰逊为这位伟人写的传记——他后来怎么了？威尔说，《丘吉尔因子》的核心目的，就是在人们的眼中扬起足够的传记沙尘，以至于当人们抬头时，再也分不清丘吉尔从哪里结束、约翰逊从哪里开始。约翰逊说，丘吉尔的批评者是势利眼，而且有点嫉妒，就像约翰逊自己一样。丘吉尔的写作是将自己戏剧化和宣传的一种方式，就像约翰逊一样。丘吉尔对党内同僚的不忠是极其壮丽的，这就变得荒谬了。在习惯上，丘吉尔——而且我找不到
another biographer who's made this claim, superficially resembled a Bertie Worcester figure, just like Johnson. Now, as ever, if you like the sound of that, a special offer awaits listeners of The Rest Is History for their daily hit of world-class writing. You get the first 10 weeks free, and thereafter, it will be just £1 a week, which is pretty much nothing, for an UnHerd subscription. So if you want to take them up on that splendid, unmissable, once-in-a-lifetime offer, then go to unherd.com slash rest. That's U-N-H-E-R-D dot com slash rest. Winston is going back to school today. Entre nous.
任何其他传记作家得出过这个结论——表面上看起来就像一个伯蒂·伍斯特（Bertie Wooster）式的人物，就像约翰逊一样。现在，一如既往地，如果你喜欢听这个，订阅《历史的余烬》的听众将享有特别优惠，可以每日获取世界一流的深度写作。你可以获得前10周免费试用，之后每周只需1英镑——这几乎等于不要钱——即可订阅 UnHerd。所以如果你想接受这个精彩绝伦、不容错过、一生仅此一次的优惠，请访问 unherd.com slash rest。网址是 U-N-H-E-R-D dot com slash rest。温斯顿今天要回学校了。私下说。
I do not feel very sorry, for he certainly is a handful. Is that Marilyn Monroe, Tom? That was Jenny Churchill. That was Winston Churchill's mother. She spoke exactly like that. Right. I assume, actually, she probably spoke in a pretty posh English accent, wouldn't she? She'd be like Kathar Catherine Hepburn, I imagine.
我其实并不觉得很难过，因为他确实是个让人头疼的捣蛋鬼。那是玛丽莲·梦露吗，汤姆？那是珍妮·丘吉尔。那是温斯顿·丘吉尔的母亲。她说话就是那个调调。好吧，我其实假设她大概说的是一口相当高档的英国腔吧？我想她听起来应该像凯瑟琳·赫本（Katharine Hepburn）。
You know, that sort of mid-Atlantic kind of slightly aristocratic kind of voice. But I imagine after, you know, 20 years hanging out with Prince of Wales, she would probably have sounded pretty Downton Abbey. Yeah, so that's, I mean, she's very much taken on the traditional upper class British attitude to children, which is basically to have nothing to do with them, and pack them off to boarding schools as soon as possible, which was very much Churchill's fate. And this was absolutely standard behaviour. I mean, this is what every upper-class parent would do. But the behaviour of Churchill's parents are exceptional, even by the standards of the age, would you say? I definitely think that it's exceptional. So yes, you're absolutely right. Lots of aristocratic
你知道的，那种大西洋中岸风格的、略带贵族气息的声音。不过我想，在和威尔士亲王厮混了20年之后，她听起来大概会非常像《唐顿庄园》里的人。是的，我的意思是，她身上带有传统上流社会英国人对孩子的典型态度，基本上就是和他们毫无瓜葛，然后尽快把他们打包送到寄宿学校去，这正是丘吉尔的命运。而这完全是标准行为。我的意思是，这是所有上流社会父母都会做的事。但丘吉尔父母的行为，即使以当时的时代标准来看，也是异乎寻常的，你觉得呢？我绝对认为这是异乎寻常的。所以是的，你完全没错，许多贵族
children were packed off to boarding school, but that doesn't mean that their parents didn't show them interest and affection outside that. What happens to Churchill is his parents show him absolutely no affection and interest at all. In fact, quite the reverse. They constantly tell him that he's a failure, that he's an annoyance, that he's an intrusion. I mean, they really bully him, actually. I mean, there's no other way of describing it i mean if it's given a couple of example i mean he said he worships his parents he idolized his father lord randolph all his life he he dreamed of emulating his father and making his father he has a dream of his father coming to see him in the war in the second World War or something like that.
儿童都被打包送去了寄宿学校，但这并不意味着他们的父母在学校之外对他们不闻不问、毫无关爱。而在丘吉尔身上发生的情况是，他的父母对他完全没有表现出任何关爱和兴趣。事实上，恰恰相反。他们不断告诉他他是个失败者、是个累赘、是个不受欢迎的入侵者。我的意思是，他们真的在霸凌他，实际上——我的意思是，找不到别的词来形容了。我的意思是，举几个例子吧。他说他崇拜他的父母，他一生都在盲目崇拜他的父亲伦道夫勋爵，他梦想着效仿他的父亲，让他的父亲……他甚至做过一个梦，梦见他的父亲在二战期间来看望他，或者类似的场景。
It's actually an incredible story. He's having dinner with his daughter and his son. And there's a spare chair. And his daughter says to Sarah, says to Churchill, if you could have anyone in that chair right now, who would you have? Thinking he's going to say Napoleon or Julius Caesar or whatever. And he says, oh, obviously my father. And that is then the cue for him to say he had a dream about his father recently, in which his father visited him as a ghost. And his family persuaded him to write this down and turn it into a little story,
这其实是一个难以置信的故事。他当时正和女儿、儿子一起吃晚饭。桌上有一把空椅子。他的女儿莎拉对丘吉尔说：“如果你现在能让任何人坐在那把椅子上，你会选谁？”她以为他会说拿破仑、尤利乌斯·恺撒之类的人物。而他说：“噢，当然是我父亲了。”这随后就成了他的引子，他接着讲述了自己最近做的一个关于父亲的梦，梦中他的父亲作为幽灵来拜访了他。他的家人说服他把这个梦写下来，变成了一个小故事，
which he did, but he never published it. It was kept within the family. And in the dream, Lord Randolph comes to visit Churchill. and where everything every time churchill tries to tell him what he's done what he's achieved you know he did save the empire he was prime minister his father interrupts him and says oh you're a total failure i'll never talk about politics with you you don't know anything about it and then just as churchill is poised to tell him what he's actually achieved in his life his father vanishes um and he never gets the chance. And of course, there's an element of sort of self-nathologizing in this story, but it clearly speaks to a deep sort of lack at the heart of Churchill. I mean, Churchill says at one point, in another occasion, he's having dinner with his
他也照做了，但他从未发表过。它一直被保存在家族内部。在梦中，伦道夫勋爵来拜访丘吉尔。每当丘吉尔试图向他讲述自己做了什么、取得了什么成就时——你知道的，他拯救了帝国，他当过首相——他的父亲总是打断他，说道：“噢，你是个彻头彻尾的失败者，我绝不跟你谈论政治，你对政治一窍不通。”然后，正当丘吉尔准备告诉他自己一生中实际取得了什么成就时，他的父亲消失了……他再也没有机会说出口。当然，这个故事中带有某种自我心理分析的成分，但它清楚地揭示了丘吉尔内心深处的某种巨大缺失。我的意思是，丘吉尔在另一个场合曾说过，
son, Randolph, named after his father in the 1930s. And at the end of the dinner, Churchill said to his son, we have this evening had a longer period of continuous conversation together than the total, which I had with my father in the whole course of his life. So they never really talked together. His mother, he worshipped his mother. He said, in my early life, he says, my mother seemed to me a fairy princess, a radiant being possessed of limitless riches and power. She shone for me like the evening star. I loved her dearly, but at a distance. And that, at a distance.
在20世纪30年代，他和以他父亲名字命名的儿子伦道夫共进晚餐。晚餐结束时，丘吉尔对儿子说：“我们今晚进行的连续谈话的时间，比我和我父亲在一生中所说过的全部话加起来还要长。”所以他们从来没有真正坐在一起好好交谈过。至于他的母亲，他崇拜他的母亲。他在《我早年的生活》中说：“我的母亲在我眼中仿佛是一位童话里的公主，一个散发着耀眼光芒的存在，拥有无限的财富和权力。她像晚星一样为我闪耀。我深爱着她，但那是保持着距离的。”而那种，保持着距离。
So when they sent him off to school, they take no interest in him. They don't answer his letters. Jenny, I mean, Andrew Roberts again in his biography, he's gone through her diaries. In 1882, in the first seven months of 1882, she sees her children 13 times. She goes shopping 11 times. She goes painting 25 times. She has lunch with her friend, Lady Blanche Hosier, 26 times. She has tea with the Conservative MP, Arthur Balfour, 10 times.
所以当他们把他送去学校时，他们对他不闻不问。他们不回他的信。安德鲁·罗伯茨在他的传记中再次查阅了她的日记。在1882年，即1882年的前七个月里，她见她孩子们的次数是13次。她去购物11次。她去画画25次。她和她的朋友布兰奇·霍齐尔夫人（Lady Blanche Hozier）吃午饭26次。她和保守党议员亚瑟·贝尔福（Arthur Balfour）喝茶10次。
She goes out to parties literally every single night. But in all this period she barely ever sees her children and when she does she resents it and she'll often write them letters saying stop asking to see me stop asking to come home at christmas all these kinds of things right so that's bad but you've talked about them bullying young winston um and telling him he's useless telling me stupid all that kind of thing and he does seem to have internalized it because one of the odd things is that it's one of the famous details of my early life in which he says that he portrays himself as a dunce, that he's absolutely hopeless, that he can barely read. He's always the bottom of the form. But clearly this isn't true. I mean,
她几乎每天晚上都要出去参加派对。但在这段时间里，她几乎从来不去看望自己的孩子，当她偶尔见到他们时，也会感到厌烦，并且经常给他们写信说，别要求见我，别要求回家过圣诞节，诸如此类的话。所以这很糟糕，但你们之前谈到过他们霸凌小温斯顿，嗯，告诉他他是个废物，告诉他他很愚蠢诸如此类的话，而他似乎也已经内化了这些评价，因为其中一个奇怪的细节是，这也是我早年生活中著名的细节之一，在其中他说，他把自己描绘成一个笨蛋，觉得自己完全无可救药，几乎连字都认不全。他总是考倒数第一。但显然这并不是真的。我是说，
he's a very bright boy. I mean, obviously he's a bright boy of course he is but but he's he's recognized by his teachers as being bright he comes you know he's top of the form in classics and all kinds of things and again he makes this great play about how you know he doesn't know any latin or greek or anything but he did so what do you think is going on there do you think this is he's trying to to show that parents' poor opinion of him was right? Or what do you think? I think we all have narratives of ourselves, don't we? I mean, no matter how humdrum our lives might appear to be, we have our own kind of romantic melodramas of our own life.
他是个非常聪明的男孩。我是说，很显然他是个聪明的男孩，当然是的，但是但他的他的聪明是得到了老师认可的，你知道的，他在古典文学等各个科目上都考过第一名，而且同样地，他极力渲染自己如何如何不懂拉丁语或希腊语之类的东西，但他明明懂啊。所以你觉得这其中是怎么回事？你觉得这是他在试图证明父母对他的低评价是正确的吗？还是你觉得是别的什么？我想我们每个人对自我都有某种叙事，对吧？我是说，无论我们的生活看起来多么平凡无奇，我们对自己的人生都有着某种浪漫的悲喜剧式的想象。
And I think Churchill more than most. And this idea that he had triumphed over a kind of Dickensian upbringing of sort of being beaten and being downtrodden, I think is very important. Well, he was beaten. Well, he was. Yes, absolutely. He was. Because his first his first head teacher was a psychopath, wasn't he? Yes. A sadist, I think is the description. Yeah. It's the kind of guy who would he would pop up in in the news of the world when it was still being published.
而且我认为丘吉尔比大多数人都要严重得多。这种他战胜了狄更斯式的成长经历——那种遭受殴打和压迫的成长经历——的观念，我认为是非常重要的。好吧，他确实挨过打。好吧，他的确挨过。是的，绝对的。他的确挨过打。因为他的第一位第一任校长是个精神病患者，不是吗？是的。我想评价他是个虐待狂。是的。就是那种会在《世界新闻报》还在发行时登上新闻头条的家伙。
Well, the sort of person from an Evelyn War novel or something. so his name is hw sneed kinnisley and churchill has a hilarious description of basically he's seven years old and somebody says to him you have to go to school and they take him to the school st george's ascot which is a kind of prep it's it's genuinely a preparatory school because it prepares you for Eton or for Harrow. And they go off and his mum has tea with the headmaster and then just leaves him. And he absolutely hates it. He is beaten all the time. One of his friends said later, they remembered him being flogged for taking sugar from the pantry. And then Churchill took the headmaster's straw hat and kicked it to pieces in rage. He's constantly in trouble with the headmaster. He's always being beaten. And actually, the school is so bad that even his parents take him out after two years.
好吧，就像伊夫林·沃小说里的人物那种。所以他的名字叫H·W·斯尼德-金斯利（H. W. Sneyd-Kynnersley），丘吉尔对这件事有一段非常搞笑的描述：基本上当时他七岁，有人对他说你得去上学了，然后他们把他带到了阿斯科特的圣乔治学校（St George's School, Ascot），这是一所预备学校，它确实是一所预备学校，因为它能为你考入伊顿公学或哈罗公学做好准备。他们出发了，他妈妈和校长喝了杯茶，然后就把他一个人留在那儿了。他简直恨透了那里。他经常挨打。他的一位朋友后来回忆说，他们记得他曾因为从食品储藏室拿了糖而遭到鞭笞。然后丘吉尔一气之下拿了校长的草帽，把它踢得粉碎。他总是给校长惹麻烦，总是挨打。事实上，这所学校太糟糕了，以至于仅仅两年后，连他的父母都把他接走了。
So he goes to Hove, doesn't he? He goes to Hove. And there's a brilliant, I mean, I thought of you when I read this. Is this the thing with Mensa? Yeah. He meets the latin teacher for the first time so that the latin teacher introduces him to the word mensa and churchill says what does what does it mean and there's the whole sort of what is it called the declension or the conjugation i can't remember the and the the guy says uh mensa means a table then why does mensa also mean o table i inquired andired. And what does O-table mean?
所以他去了霍夫，对吧？他去了霍夫。这里有一个绝妙的桥段——我在读到这段时想到了你。这就是关于“Mensa”那个事吗？是的。他第一次遇到拉丁语老师，拉丁语老师向他引出了“Mensa”这个词，丘吉尔问这是什么意思，然后有一整套类似于——它叫什么来着——变格或变位，我记不清了，然后那个人说“嗯，Mensa的意思是桌子”。“那为什么Mensa也代表‘哦，桌子’呢？”我追问。那“哦，桌子”又是什么意思？
Mensa O-table is the vocative case, says the teacher. And Churchill says, and the teacher then says, well, this is what you would use in addressing a table, in invoking a table. You would use it in speaking to a table, Churchill says. But I never do speak to a table. And then the teacher loses his temper and says, you're impertinent you'll be punished and punished let me tell you very severely and Churchill then has this wonderful line such was my first introduction to the classics from which I have been told many of our cleverest men have derived so much solace and profit and this is the thing that he paints himself as the philistine who
“Mensa的‘哦，桌子’是呼格，”老师说。丘吉尔说，接着老师又说：“嗯，这就是你在称呼一张桌子、向一张桌子祈求时会用到的形式。你在跟一张桌子说话时就会用它，”丘吉尔说，“但我从来不跟桌子说话。”然后老师大发雷霆，说：“你太无礼了，我要狠狠地惩罚你，狠狠地惩罚你。”丘吉尔接着写下了这句精彩绝伦的话：“这就是我最初接触古典文学的经历，据说许多最聪明的人正是从中获得了无数的慰藉与收益。”这就是他把自己塑造成一个——
doesn't understand latin and. But also someone who, because he then he has the famous line, doesn't he, that because he's not focusing on Latin and Greek, therefore he gets instruction in English. And thus I got into my bones, the central structure of the ordinary British sentence, which is a noble thing.
不懂拉丁语的市侩。但也正因如此，正如他随后那句名言所说的那样，因为他不专注于拉丁语和希腊语，所以他接受了英语的指导。因此，普通英国句子的核心结构——一种崇高的事物——深深融入了他的骨髓。
Wonderful phrase. The ordinary British sentence, a noble thing. And it casts him, even as he is unapologetically aristocratic, he's also able to portray himself as the voice of the common man. Well, exactly, because this is when he's gone to Harrow. So he then goes to Harrow. He doesn't go to Eton, which might seem a surprise.
美妙的词句。普通英国句子，一种崇高的事物。这塑造了他的形象：尽管他毫不掩饰自己的贵族身份，但他同时也能够把自己塑造为普通民众的代言人。没错，因为这是在他去了哈罗公学之后。所以他随后进入了哈罗公学。他没有去伊顿公学，这可能让人感到意外。
Harrow was fashionable at the end of the 19th century because it was on a hill. And so people thought, oh, it's healthy. You'll escape from the fetid air of London and breathe the clean air of Harrow on the hill. So he does the entrance exam in 1888. And he says, it was remarkable because I was found unable to answer a single question in the Latin paper.
在19世纪末，哈罗公学非常时髦，因为它建在一座小山上。因此人们认为，哦，这里很健康。你可以逃离伦敦污浊的空气，呼吸哈罗山清新的空气。所以在1888年，他参加入学考试。他说，这太奇妙了，因为我发现自己在拉丁语试卷上连一道题也答不上来。
I wrote my name at the top of the page. I wrote down the number of the question. One. After much reflection, I put a bracket around it. One. But thereafter, I could not think of anything connected with the question that was either relevant or true. So he leaves it completely blank.
我在页面最上方写下了自己的名字。我写下了题号。一。经过深思熟虑，我在它周围画了一个括号。一。但在此之后，我想不出任何与这道题相关、或正确的内容。于是他完全交了白卷。
And he gets into Harrow anyway. Or so he says. Yeah, so he says on the basis of his contacts and so on but he's put in the lowest form isn't he i mean he sort of says it was the darkest time in his life uh he was beaten all the time he was always in the bottom form and this is a bit of an exaggeration because as his biographers say he writes for the school magazine he wins poetry prizes he wins a fencing competition yes that's public that's quite a big deal that's not nothing but also harrow is byron's school and byron was a great one for keeping pets and churchill's very into that in that tradition so he keeps a bulldog a bulldog i
但他还是考进了哈罗公学。他是这么说的。是的，他是说靠着自己的人脉等等，但他被分到了最低的班级，不是吗？我是说，他有点说这是他一生中最黑暗的时期，嗯，他一直在挨打，他总是在最底层的班级，这其实有点夸张，因为正如他的传记作家所说，他为学校杂志撰稿，他赢得过诗歌奖，他赢得过击剑比赛——是的，那是公开的，这可是件相当大的事，这并非微不足道。而且哈罗公学也是拜伦的母校，拜伦非常喜欢养宠物，丘吉尔也完全继承了这一传统，所以他养了一只斗牛犬，一只斗牛犬，我——
mean he couldn't make that no i mean it's he's also consistently rude to the teachers i mean he's been that all through his life so there's's a famous story that one teacher says to him when they're 14. He says, I don't know what to do with you boys. And Churchill shouts out, teacher, sir. And the other one is that he was called to see the headmaster who said, Churchill, I have very grave reason to be displeased with you. And Churchill unbelievably said, and I, sir, have very grave reason to be displeased with you, for which clearly he was obviously beaten. And then he's beaten by the head boy at one point, who while he's beating him, Churchill says to him, I shall be a greater man than you.
我是说，他真干得出来。不，我是说，他对老师也一直很不客气。我是说他一辈子都这样，所以有个著名的故事：当他们14岁时，一个老师对他说，我不知道该拿你们这帮男孩怎么办。丘吉尔大喊：“老师，长官！”另一个故事是，他被叫去见校长，校长说：“丘吉尔，我有非常严重的理由对你感到不满。”丘吉尔竟然难以置信地回答说：“而我，长官，也有非常严重的理由对您感到不满。”显然，为此他理所当然地挨了一顿打。后来，他又被首席生殴打过一次，就在挨打的时候，丘吉尔对他说：“我会比你更伟大。”
And this head boy goes on to be the Bishop of Lincoln. Very Episcopal behavior. But also he he pushes... They're standing by the swimming pool, aren't they? The Harrow. Yeah. And there's a small-looking boy standing with his back to Churchill. So Churchill does the obvious thing and pushes him in.
而这个首席生后来成了林肯主教。非常符合主教的行为举止。不仅如此，他还推了……他们正站在游泳池边，对吧？哈罗的泳池。嗯，有一个看起来个头不大的男孩背对着丘吉尔站着。于是丘吉尔做了显而易见的事——把他推了下去。
And this is very bad because... Do you know what you've done? It's Avery. He's in the sixth form. He's the head of his house. He's the champion at gym. He's got his football colours. Oh, no.
这可就糟了，因为……你知道你推的是谁吗？那是艾利里（Avery）。他是六年级的。他是他宿舍的负责人。他是体操冠军。他拿到了足球校队资格。噢，不。
Churchill's very apologetic, not because he's pushed him into the swimming pool per se, but because he's pushed someone who's got his football colours and his head boy, head of the house or whatever. And he says to Leo Amory, I'm very sorry. My father, who is a great man, is also small. And this probably doesn't go down tremendously well either. But Leo Amory, of course, is a figure who will reappear over the course of Churchill's early life. And then in due course, of course, the events of the Second World War. Well, Leo Amory is the man who says, in the name of God, go to Neville Chamberlain in the Norway debates that paves the way for Churchill to be. And actually, Dominic, I mean, one of the things that's interesting about looking at Churchill's early life is how often he comes up against people who will, you know, have significant roles to play in subsequent decades.
丘吉尔非常抱歉，倒不是因为他把人推到了游泳池里本身，而是因为他推了一个拥有足球校队资格、而且还是首席生、宿舍长之类的人。他对利奥·艾利里（Leo Amory）说：“非常抱歉。我父亲是个伟大的人，但他个子也很小。”这可能同样没能起到什么好作用。但利奥·艾利里当然是会在丘吉尔早年生活中再次出现的人物。然后理所当然地，在后来的第二次世界大战中也有他的戏份。好吧，利奥·艾利里就是在挪威辩论中对内维尔·张伯伦说出“看在上帝的份上，走吧”的那个人，正是这场辩论为丘吉尔的上台铺平了道路。事实上，多米尼克，我是说，回顾丘吉尔的早年生活，有趣的一点在于，他有多少次会与那些在随后的几十年里扮演重要角色的人狭路相逢。
And of course, you realize that that's what public schools are for, that, you know, they are breeding grounds of chaps who will then meet up and kind of run India or board of trade or that kind of stuff. So Churchill, some people would say he has this gilded, absolutely gilded background. He has all these opportunities. He makes all these friends and contacts. And yet at the same time, and again, I really would stress, this is not really the norm. It's easy to parody and caricature and say, oh, all 19th century people treated their children
当然，你会意识到公学就是为此而存在的，你知道的，它们是这群年轻人的温床，他们日后会相聚并管理印度、贸易委员会之类的事情。所以丘吉尔，有些人会说他有着镀金般的、绝对镀金的背景。他拥有所有的机会。他结交了所有的朋友和人脉。然而与此同时——我还是要再次强调，这其实并不是常态。我们很容易去讽刺、刻意夸大，然后说，哦，所有19世纪的人都是用——
with hatred and contempt but Churchill is getting letters well he's writing letters to his parents that say things like this please do do do do do do come down to see me please do come I've been so disappointed so many times about your coming and then his mother just ignores these these letters or she writes back and says things like this your father and I his his mother just ignores these these letters or she writes back and says things like this your father and i are both more disappointed in you than we can say i dare say you have a thousand excuses you make me very unhappy your work is an insult to your intelligence etc etc so at one point they tell him he can't come home at christmas i mean that's a pretty big deal for a boy who's at the boarding school to be told he can't come home at christmas
充满恨意和蔑视的态度对待自己的孩子，但丘吉尔收到的信件——好吧，其实是他给父母写信，信里写着这样的话：“求求你，求求你，求求你一定要来看看我，求求你一定要来，因为你没来，我已经失望过太多次了。”然后他的母亲只是无视这些信件，或者她回信写道：“你父亲和我——”他的母亲只是无视这些信件，或者她回信写道：“你父亲和我对你的失望简直无以复加，我敢说你有一千个借口，你让我太不开心了，你的功课是对你智商的侮辱，等等等等。”所以有一段时间，他们告诉他圣诞节不能回家。我是说，对于一个寄宿学校的男孩来说，被告知圣诞节不能回家，这可是件相当大的事。
they're going to send him to france instead with a French family for help is French. And he writes this letter to his mother, which is absolutely heartrending. My darling mummy, never would I have believed you could be so unkind. I'm so utterly miserable. I can't tell you how wretched you've made me feel. Oh, my mummy, I expect you were too busy with your parties and arrangements for Christmas. I comfort myself by this. I am more unhappy than I can possibly say your loving son,
相反，他们要把他送到法国，和一个法国家庭一起生活以学习法语。他给母亲写了一封信，简直让人心碎。我亲爱的妈妈，我简直不敢相信你会如此冷酷无情。我感到彻底的痛苦，无法向您倾诉您让我感到的痛苦。哦，我的妈妈，我猜您一定是因为忙于派对和圣诞节的筹备而无暇顾及。我以此来安慰自己。我比我能表达的还要不开心，您慈爱的儿子，
Winnie. She is outraged by this. She ignores him. He writes again, please, my darling mummy, be kind to your loving son. Don't let my silly letter make you so angry.
温妮。她对此大发雷霆。她对置之不理。他又写信道：求求你，我亲爱的妈妈，对你亲爱的儿子好一点吧。别让我的傻信让你这么生气。
And then she, she basically says to her friends, Winston has been the most awful pain. He wants to come home at Christmas because she wants to see she's having an affair with the Austrian ambassador Prince Kinski and Count Kinski rather and she doesn't want and so she just ignores all these letters or she says Winston and sometimes she'll write him and she'll say I saw you you wrote me another of these drippy letters I haven't even opened it you make me sick you're kind of you're such a failure and all this stuff but Dominic meanwhile I mean talking being a failure talking being a failure, talking being a failure, meanwhile,
然后她，她基本上对她的朋友们说，温斯顿简直是个大麻烦。他想在圣诞节回家，因为她想去会情郎——她正在和奥地利驻英国大使金斯基亲王（Prince Kinski）、或者说伯爵（Count Kinski）偷情，她不希望这样，所以她干脆无视所有这些信件，或者她会对温斯顿写信说，我看到你了，你又给我写了这种无病呻吟的信，我甚至都没拆开它，你真让我作呕，你简直是个彻头彻尾的失败者，诸如此类。但多米尼克，与此同时，我是说，说到成为失败者，说到成为失败者，说到成为失败者，与此同时，
Lord Randolph Churchill's career, you know, he's hit the heights and then he's plummeted completely, hasn't he? So he's crashed and burned. Yeah, he has. He's, I mean, we talked about him as utterly unreliable. So he has, he reached the pinnacle really in the late 1880s, 1885, 86. He had campaigned very successfully around the country, sort of rabble-rousing for the Tories, Lord Salisbury's party.
伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵的政治生涯，你知道的，他曾达到过巅峰，然后彻底一落千丈，不是吗？所以他彻底撞毁并烧毁了自己的前途。是的，他确实如此。他，我是说，我们之前谈过他极不可靠。所以他在19世纪80年代末、1885、1886年左右确实达到了巅峰。他曾在全国各地进行了非常成功的竞选活动，为保守党——索尔兹伯里勋爵的党派——煽动民众。
They win. Lord Salisbury makes him Chancellor of the Exchequer. And then Lord Randolph, after five months, basically, he decides he's going to flounce out or threaten to flounce out about some defence spending, which he says is too high. It's basically just a sort of trial of strength. He's just showing off. And he doesn't think Lord Salisbury will accept his resignation.
他们赢了。索尔兹伯里勋爵任命他为财政大臣。然后伦道夫勋爵在五个月后，基本上决定拍拍屁股走人，或者以国防开支过高为由威胁要辞职。这基本上只是一场实力测试。他只是在炫耀。而且他根本不认为索尔兹伯里勋爵会接受他的辞职。
Or call his bluff. Call his bluff. And Lord Salisbury just says, oh, right. Okay, fine. Off you go. And that's the end of Lord Randolph Churchill's entire political career. He just ludicrously shot himself in the foot. And from that point onwards, he goes into this terrible decline.
或者说，他觉得索尔兹伯里不敢接招。不敢跟他的牌。而索尔兹伯里勋爵只是说：“哦，好吧。行，没问题。请便。”伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵的整个政治生涯也就此画上了句号。他简直是荒谬地搬起石头砸了自己的脚。从那一刻起，他陷入了可怕的衰落之中。
Which I had always thought was syphilis but it seems may not be no i think churchill was very very sensitive to the thought that his father might have had syphilis and he hated the idea and always tried to play it but but it now seems that he may have been some kind of brain illness i think um uh rather than the truth is is, of course, as always, where we try to sort of medicalise these things, to diagnose illnesses that are long distant, we can't really know. And in a way, maybe it doesn't matter.
我以前一直以为那是梅毒，但现在看来似乎并非如此。不，我认为丘吉尔对“他的父亲可能患有梅毒”这种想法非常非常敏感，他痛恨这个主意，并总是极力掩饰。但现在看来，那可能某种脑部疾病，我想，嗯……比起真相本身，当然，一如既往地，当我们试图将这些事情医学化、去诊断那些遥远年代的疾病时，我们其实无法确切知道。从某种意义上说，也许这并不重要。
What matters is that Lord Randolph goes into this terrible decline. And that, again, I think Churchill is a really interesting object lesson in temperament. Because with most people people this background of your parents treating you like dirt telling you you're a failure your father himself being a failure and all this it would sort of crush you don't you think yeah i do you would become a very bitter maybe introverted shy slightly sort of downtrodden person i certainly i would i think churchill never reacts really like that.
重要的是，伦道夫勋爵陷入了可怕的衰落。再次，我认为丘吉尔是关于性格的一个非常有趣的案例。因为对大多数人来说，如果父母把你当垃圾一样对待、告诉你你是个失败者、你的父亲本身也是个失败者，诸如此类，这会彻底击垮你，你不觉得吗？是的，我确实这么觉得。你可能会变成一个非常痛苦、也许内向、害羞、甚至有点受压迫感的人。我肯定会是的。但我认为丘吉尔从未那样反应过。
I mean, it makes him desperate to be the centre of attention, desperate to sort of win applause and friends and so on. But he also has this sort of tremendous generosity of spirit, which must be innate, because he definitely doesn't get it from his parents. Well, maybe he gets it from his beloved nanny, who he unbelievably calls a woomy. Because he definitely doesn't get it from his parents. Well, maybe he gets it from his beloved nanny, who he unbelievably calls a woomy.
我是说，这让他极度渴望成为注意力的中心，极度渴望赢得掌声和朋友等等。但他也有一种非常巨大的精神慷慨，这必定是天生的，因为他绝对不是从父母那里继承来的。好吧，也许他是从他深爱的保姆那里继承的，他难以置信地称她为“乌米”（woomy）。因为他绝对不是从父母那里继承来的。好吧，也许他是从他深爱的保姆那里继承的，他难以置信地称她为“乌米”。
Yeah, he calls her womb or woominy. It's very Freudian, isn't it, Tom? I mean, it couldn't be more Freudian. And he absolutely loves her. And she's from Kent, or she has family in Kent. I can't remember which. She's always telling him Kent is so beautiful. And, of course, Churchill ends up with a house in Kent, or she has family in Kent. I can't remember which. She's always telling him Kent is so beautiful. And, of course, Churchill ends up with a house in Kent, Chartwell,
是的，他叫她“ womb ”或“ woominy ”。这非常弗洛伊德，对吧，汤姆？我是说，这简直不能再弗洛伊德了。他非常爱她。她来自肯特郡，或者她的家人在肯特郡。我记不清了。她总是告诉他肯特郡有多美。当然，丘吉尔最终在肯特郡拥有一栋房子——或者她的家人在肯特郡。我记不清了。她总是告诉他肯特郡有多美。当然，丘吉尔最终在肯特郡拥有了一座房子，也就是查特韦尔（Chartwell），
and becomes obsessed with Kent and the Garden of England and stuff. He invites her to Harrow, walks around with her, devoted to her. And he's mocked by the other boys for walking around in the street arm in arm with his former nanny. Yeah. But, again, it's his self-confidence that he would do that because having been a boarding school boy myself, that's the absolute last thing I would have ever conceived of doing is walking around with a sort of an elderly lady arm in arm
并且开始痴迷于肯特郡和“英格兰的花园”之类的事物。他邀请她去哈罗公学，和她一起散步，对她深情厚谊。结果他在街上和前保姆挽着胳膊散步，遭到了其他男孩的嘲笑。是的。但话说回来，他能这么做正是因为他有着强大的自信。因为作为一个曾经的寄宿学校男生，我绝对无法想象自己会做的一件事，就是和一个老妇人挽着胳膊，
through the streets while the other boys hurled abuse. Hurled it, yes. But inevitably she gets sacked by his evil parents when she's 19, cast off. But Churchill's very decent, isn't he? And no bless oblige, looks after her. Yes, he absolutely does have it. No bless oblige is the right phrase, Tom. He really has a strong sense of that, doesn't he? Well, yes, because he has no qualms about the idea that he is born to greatness. I mean,
走在街道上，而周围的其他男孩则对我们大声辱骂。大声辱骂，是的。但不可避免的是，在他19岁时，她被他邪恶的父母解雇并被抛弃了。但丘吉尔非常正派，对吧？他有贵族义务（noblesse oblige）的精神，照顾着她。是的，他确实有。贵族义务（noblesse oblige）是个恰当的词，汤姆。他确实有很强的这种意识，不是吗？嗯，是的，因为他对于“自己生来就注定伟大”这一观念毫无心理负担。我是说，
he's unapologetic about that. We talked about that. But he does feel that it brings responsibilities. I mean, that's really the core of his politics, would you say, and perhaps his entire morality. And also, I think that's an element of his attitude to the empire, that the British should rule, but that they should look after the people that they rule. Yeah, I don't think there's anything, of course, listeners will have very strong views about this, but I don't think there's anything in Churchill's makeup that is terribly rapacious or personally exploitative. He is a classic paternalist, isn't he? He thinks it's his duty. He thinks, as you say, he's from a superior class. He'll never travel in a second class carriage on a train, but he thinks it's his duty to provide for those who do travel in the
他对此毫不掩饰。我们之前聊过这个。但他确实觉得这带来了责任。我是说，这真的是他政治的核心，你会这么说吗？也许也是他整个人生道德的核心。而且，我也认为这是他对帝国态度的一部分：英国人应当统治，但他们也应当照顾被统治的人民。是的，我不认为有什么——当然，听众对这一点会有强烈的看法——我不认为丘吉尔的性格中有任何极其贪婪或纯粹个人剥削的成分。他是个典型的温情保守主义者，不是吗？他认为这是他的职责。正如你所说，他认为自己属于一个更优越的阶层。他绝不会坐火车的二等车厢，但他认为照顾那些坐火车的人是他的职责所在——
second class carriage or indeed the third- or fourth-class carriages. And of course, he's often very snobbish and arrogant and all of these kinds of things. Yeah, so writing about Wumi, Elizabeth Everest, his nanny, when she dies, she had lived such an innocent and loving life of service to others and held such a simple faith that she had no fears at all and did not seem to mind very much. He's writing about her dying. She had been my dearest and most intimate friend during the whole of the 20 years i had lived and he pays for the upkeep of her grave for the rest of his life so churchill isn't incredibly
二等车厢，甚至是三等或四等车厢。当然，他常常表现得非常势利、傲慢，诸如此类。是的，所以当他的保姆伊丽莎白·埃弗雷斯特（Elizabeth Everest）去世时，他写道：“她过着一种如此天真、充满爱意、服务他人的生活，并怀抱着如此单纯的信仰，以至于她毫无恐惧，也似乎并不怎么在意死亡。”他在写她濒临死亡时的情况。“在我活着的整整二十年里，她一直是我最亲爱、最亲密的友人。”而且他包办了她余生墓地的维护费用。所以丘吉尔并不是一个极其冷酷的人——
he's a perfect example of somebody he's incredibly sentimental he cries a lot you know he's never afraid of crying of crying in public of talking about crying he isn't he's never afraid of crying, of crying in public, of talking about crying. He is never afraid of kind of overt, ostentatious displays of emotion. I mean, famously, you know, we're recording this podcast a week or so after the death of the Queen. Churchill would burst into tears when he saw her portrait when she became Queen in the 1950s. He's a kind of hardened political campaigner. His emotions are incredibly vivid and he paints them in very, very bright colours. And I guess had he lived a less flamboyant, dramatic, heroic life, it would look ridiculous.
他是一个极其多愁善感的完美例子。他经常哭泣，你知道的，他从不害怕哭泣，从不害怕在公众面前哭泣，从不害怕谈论哭泣。他从不害怕公开、炫耀式地流露情感。我是说，众所周知，我们录制这期播客时，正值女王去世一周左右。在20世纪50年代女王登基时，丘吉尔看到她的画像就会情不自禁地泪流满面。他是一个身经百战的政治竞选人。他的情感极其鲜艳，并且他用极其鲜艳的色彩来描绘它们。我想，如果他过着一种不那么张扬、戏剧化、英雄主义的生活，这一切看起来就会很荒谬。
Yeah. But he leads a life that is equal to the bright colours in which he paints his own emotions. And he's insanely brave as well. I mean, he seems to take risks purely for the sake of it. So he leaves Harrow. And in January 1893, he goes to stay with some cousins at Wimborne. And just for the fun of it it he jumps off a footbridge
是的。但他过着一种与他用来描绘自己情感的鲜艳色彩相匹配的生活。而且他有着疯狂的勇敢。我是说，他似乎纯粹为了冒险而冒险。所以他离开了哈罗公学。1893年1月，他去温伯姆（Wimborne）探望一些表亲。只是为了好玩，
and he assumes you know there are kind of branches of trees underneath and they will break his fall but they don't break his fall and his foot is about 30 feet or something and there's a kind of hard road underneath and you know it's insane he kind of ruptures his kidney he breaks a bone in his back and they only find that out in uh you know he has an x-ray in the 50s and it's also pointless but so kind of tiggerish oh here's a bridge i'll jump off it just for fun he's very tiggerish that there are so many incidents like that aren't there in his late so the next sort of 10 years of his life he's always falling off boats, almost drowning, you know, leaping off this.
他从一座人行桥上跳了下去。他以为，你知道的，下面会有一些树枝可以缓冲他的下落，但树枝并没有缓冲他的下落，大约30英尺高的落差，下面是一条坚硬的马路。你知道，这太疯狂了。他差不多摔裂了肾脏，脊椎骨也骨折了——直到50年代他拍X光时才发现这一点。这一切毫无意义，却又那么像跳跳虎（Tigger）式的冲动：“哦，这里有座桥，我为了好玩跳下去吧。”他太像跳跳虎了，他的早年生活中——在接下来的大约10年里——到处都是这样的事件，不是吗？总是从船上掉下来，差点淹死，从各种地方跳下去……
He plays a lot of polo and is always being injured and so on. He is very physically brave. I suppose he feels he has to be to some extent because he already thinks of himself as a character in an imperial drama. So he's determined to go to Sandhurst to join the army. Politics is always at the back of his mind because he idolizes his father. He's seen his father in the House of Commons.
他打很多马球，总是受伤，等等。他身体确实非常勇敢。我想他觉得自己在某种程度上必须如此，因为他已经把自己视为帝国戏剧中的一个角色。因此他决心去桑赫斯特（Sandhurst）参军。政治始终在他的脑海深处，因为他崇拜他的父亲。他曾在下议院见过他的父亲。
He's met a lot of politicians. But the army seems the obvious kind of stepping stone. He's sung all the patriotic songs at Harrow. He absolutely has a faith in the empire and his sort of part. And he goes to, he takes the Sandhurst exam. The first two times he fails to get in. So this is the great military training college, the officer's college. And is Lord Randolph Churchill supportive when his son fails?
他见过许多政治家。但军队似乎是显而易见的跳板。他在哈罗公学唱过所有的爱国歌曲。他对帝国以及自己在其中的角色有着绝对的信仰。他去参加了桑赫斯特的入学考试。前两次他都没能考上。所以这是那所伟大的军事训练学院、军官学校。当儿子落榜时，伦道夫·丘吉尔勋爵给予支持了吗？
No. Well, this is the thing. So Churchill passes on his third attempt, but he doesn't get into the infantry. So perhaps slightly counterintuitively for people who don't know much about the British army, it's the infantry regiments that are more prestigious. So the guards regiments, for example. But Churchill gets into the cavalry and he came 95th out of 389. I mean, that's not terrible.
没有。嗯，这就是关键所在。所以丘吉尔在第三次尝试时通过了，但他没能考入步兵团。对于不了解英国陆军的人来说，这可能有点违反直觉：步兵团其实更具声望。比如近卫步兵团。但丘吉尔考入了骑兵团，他在389人中排名第95位。我是说，这不算太糟。
That's not bad at all. And this is what his father wrote to him. So Churchill reproduced some of this letter in my early life, but he didn't reproduce the whole letter verbatim, probably because he says it's one of the most damning things he'd ever read about himself. And it may be because he's so cut and hurt by it. His father said, you appear to be much pleased that you've got into Sandhurst. The first extremely discreditable failure of your performance was missing the infantry, for in that failure is demonstrated beyond refutation your slovenly happy-go-lucky harem scale start of work for which you have been distinguished at your different schools never have i received a really good report of your conduct in your work from any master or tutor always behind hand never advancing in your, incessant complaints of total
一点也不算坏。而这就是他父亲写给他的信。因此，丘吉尔在《早年生活》中引用了这封信的一部分，但他没有逐字引用整封信，大概是因为他说这是他读过的关于自己的最严厉的评价之一。这可能是因为他为此感到极其痛苦和受伤。他父亲写道：“你似乎对自已考入桑赫斯特感到非常高兴。你表现出的第一次极其丢脸的失败，就是没能考入步兵团。因为这次失败无可辩驳地证明了你在不同学校里所表现出的那种散漫、随性、敷衍了事的学习态度。我从未从任何一位老师或导师那里得到过关于你品行或学业的真正好评。总是落在后面，在学习上从不长进，不断有人抱怨你完全缺乏——”
want of application. He goes on and on like this. I no longer attach the slightest weight to anything you may say about your own accomplishments and exploits. Make this position indelibly impressed in your mind that if your conduct and action is similar to what it has been in the other establishments, then my responsibility for you is over. If you cannot prevent yourself from leading the idle, useless, unprofitable life that you have had during your school days, you will become a mere social waste of hundreds of public school failures, and you will degenerate into a shabby, unhappy, and futile existence. And if that is so, you will have to bear all the blame for such misconduct.
应用能力。他喋喋不休地写个没完。我不再对你关于自己成就和功绩的任何言论给予丝毫信任。让这个立场深深烙印在你的脑海里：如果你的品行和行动与在其他学校时一样，那么我对你的责任就到此为止。如果你不能阻止自己过那种在校期间游手好闲、毫无用处、毫无益处的生活，你就会沦为一个成百上千名公学失败者中的普通社会寄生虫，最终堕落为一种寒酸、痛苦而徒劳的存在。如果真是这样，你将独自承担这种不良行径的所有指责。
Well, June, yourself, your affectionate father, Randolph Spencer Churchill. I think if there are any parents listening with children who get school reports, there's an absolute model of how to respond there. Yeah. And your child too can grow up to be like Winston Churchill. Because as you say, he gets this kicking, you know, these repeated kickings from the man that he hero worships more than any other. And instead of embittering him, it just seems to make him more and more determined that he's going to prove himself.
祝好，你的慈父，伦道夫·斯宾塞·丘吉尔。我想，如果有任何父母在听这期节目，且正为孩子拿到学校成绩单而发愁，这绝对是一个如何回应的模范样本。是的。你的孩子也可以长大后成为温斯顿·丘吉尔。因为正如你所说，他挨了这记重拳，你知道的，被他最崇拜、远超其他任何人的那个男人反复痛击。然而，这并没有让他变得苦涩，反而似乎让他更加坚决地要证明自己。
And essentially, he wants to prove himself through insane displays of courage and bravery that in turn will make a name for himself and will then enable him to get ahead in parliament and become a great man. I mean, would you say that, I'm maybe being a bit reductionist there, but that essentially is his life plan? His plan is to have adventures. Churchill has read, you know, King Solomon's minds. He's read all the imperial stories. He loves them. Even though he hated his time at Harrow, it has kind of entered into his soul and he has this shining model of his father that he wants to emulate and also if his mother who is this fairy princess monstrous person who he idolizes and he thinks of as this kind of she's like a kind of medieval damsel or something in his mind isn't she i mean he's what's his fairy
本质上，他希望通过疯狂展现勇气和勇敢来证明自己，这反过来会为他赢得名声，并使他能够在议会中崭露头角，成为一个伟大的人。我是说，你会不会觉得——我可能有点过于简化了——但这基本上就是他的人生规划？他的计划就是去冒险。丘吉尔读过《所罗门王的宝藏》，读过所有帝国的传奇故事。他热爱这些。尽管他讨厌在哈罗公学的时光，但它已经融入了他的灵魂，他心中有着一个想要效仿的光辉父亲形象，以及他母亲的形象——一个仙女公主般的存在，一个他所崇拜、并视为某种中世纪少女般的人物，不是吗？我是说，他心中的童话女王之类的人物，他极力想要给她留下深刻印象。
tale queen or something and he's desperate to impress her. And as you say, he has this dream that he will do it by performing acts of immense physical courage for the empire and then becoming a politician. And the incredible thing is that he does it. Right. So I think we should take a break at this point. He has left school. He's gone to Sandhurst.
正如你所说，他怀揣着这样一个梦想：他将通过为帝国做出巨大的体能勇敢行为，然后成为一名政客，来达成这一目标。而不可思议的是，他真的做到了。没错。所以我想我们此时应该休息一下。他已经离开了学校。他去了桑赫斯特。
He graduates from Sandhurst pretty well. He comes 20th, doesn't't he out of i can't remember how many but i mean you know yeah 20 130 that's pretty good again pretty good he's shown himself to be good at riding and polo and all the essential qualifications to be a british officer and in a sense the world is now his oyster because he can go out and have these adventures um and prove himself and in the second part of our epic survey of the life of young churchill we will um we'll see what he gets up to we'll find ourselves in cuba won't we tom we find ourselves in cuba we'll find ourselves in the northwest frontier and we will find ourselves in the sudan so loads to look forward
他以相当不错的成绩从桑赫斯特毕业。他在——我不记得具体人数了，反正——名列第20位，对吧？对，20/130，相当不错了。再次说明，相当不错。他展现了自己擅长骑马、马球以及成为一名英国军官的所有必备素质。从某种意义上说，世界现在任由他驰骋，因为他可以出去经历这些冒险，证明自己。在我们对年轻丘吉尔生平的史诗级回顾的第二部分中，我们将——我们将看看他都做了些什么。我们会发现自己身处古巴，对吧，汤姆？我们会发现自己身处古巴，会发现自己身处西北边境，还会发现自己身处苏丹。所以有很多精彩内容值得期待。
to we'll be back with part two on th, and then we'll be back again next Monday for the final concluding episode in this epic Young Churchill trilogy. Now, if you simply can't wait till then to hear the rest of the series, all three episodes are available right now to, you guessed it, members of the Rest Is History Club.
我们将在周四回归第二部分，然后在下周一回归这三部曲的最终完结篇。现在，如果你实在等不及想听完剩余的系列节目，所有三集现在都已经上线，正如你所猜的那样，仅供“历史就是一切”俱乐部（Rest Is History Club）的会员收看。
Now, if you'd like to become a member and indeed a friend of the show, then just head to restishistorypod.com to sign up. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host
现在，如果你想成为会员，甚至成为节目的朋友，只需前往 restishistorypod.com 注册即可。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史就是一切》。想要收听独家番外、抢先体验无广告节目并加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持——
The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment
《娱乐就是一切》（The Rest Is Entertainment），这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，
and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets
并向你揭示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、番外节目以及提前获取现场门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。